i'm looking at your feet and it's all
your stuff with your kids with odin's
i think you were doing a crab rave dance
on time
and i'm like this is this is a whole
different side of you i mean
how does that feel to be like you said
it's a silver lining to be
at home with the kids is it a new
appreciation as a dad
yeah i mean as a father um
you know it's the things that that i get
to see
you know through their eyes and
experience uh like such
like this crap i'll be uh discovering
stuff on youtube as i'm trying to watch
things
to occupy help them occupy some time um
so they're not running around everywhere
and um you know that was one of the
things i came across and
we do these uh dance parties in the
living room so i guess you could say
that's sort of our
cardio and staying in shape you know
even though i've put on some weight
you know yeah but you know but
you know we we're jumping around living
room and we're having fun
um and just just uh being a family
really that's what happened with this uh
foundation
with cure for the kids um which is why
we're talking uh you know i started
thinking about
you know i have i'm blessed to have a
great
family two healthy children and you know
and
and um you know my wife and you know i
started thinking about other people
i started thinking about you know during
you know this the pandemic and how other
people are feeling
and uh definitely one of the things that
affects me is
um you know childhood cancer um
and how people now in in
especially now during the pandemic now
are losing their insurance
uh people can't afford things you know
and and
and so i started thinking about you know
what can i do to give back and that's
when i
contacted some friends of mine and i
visited this clinic before
um when i because i live in las vegas a
while ago and i
was able to go through and see how
incredible they actually were what they
were doing
um to help people in nevada and also
neighboring states so i just started
thinking about other people
really and and how we could find a way
to give back and
that's why i connected with this um this
uh clinic uh
cure for the kids and you can go to
carefulthekids.org
and you can donate if you want to but it
really became
less about myself and more about
everyone else
yeah it changes you it really does yeah
because you're able to really sit back
and think about like you said you know
you're you're looking at
your your life you're looking at your
kids you know you're looking at
you know where you're at and and you
start thinking you know
that there's a bigger world out there
than yourself
how can people get involved with the
foundation yeah the um
the foundation you can you can go to
careforthekids.org and
you can learn about the uh the place um
the clinic
it was really a special place if you
want to donate you can
um but when we were here during the las
vegas residency
with the boys one of the things that i
started to connect with was all these
different foundations outside of the
strip and different things in the
community that
you know finding ways we can give back
and that's when i kind of stumbled upon
this place and
i walked in to the to the facility i
walked uh
all through it annette who runs the
place and
saw how they were doing cutting edge you
know
breakthroughs and in ways they were able
to help families and
um so you know it just it was a really
special place and
and how they were how they were
approaching it with
the way that they that that it felt
inside you know
the the feeling there was a there was
just this great just
just uh uplifting uh spirit and going
throughout the place and
and so um i felt like it was it was
definitely something that i wanted to be
involved with but
answering the question you can go to
curefitgiz.org to learn more about it
how are the boys doing i mean like you
said you were with them in vegas and
are you guys zoom calling having zoom
parties yeah we
we um are staying in touch with each
other as much as possible
uh zoom parties um we were actually in
the middle of doing
a podcast for the boys it was apple
podcast
um and so that's one of the ways we stay
in touch and also we're talking about
you know
when and when things come back you know
once everything is safe
and better you know what we're gonna do
what we would like to do
we still have a tour to kind of launch
again
the the dates are still on the books um
but of course it's more important you
know to
see how things sort of unfold and make
sure that
you know everything everyone is safe
first and foremost but um
you know we're trying to find clever
ways of
making music maybe doing a single maybe
starting to record
you know christmas record maybe is the
christmas record happening right
the christmas record is not happening
this year um but i actually got
on the phone with some of the guys the
other day and we're really
we're getting just a little antsy you
know we want to do some stuff and that's
another reason why i'm in the studio
right now too is i'm
you know i'm doing a solo record and um
you know we're all trying to find
you know ways to be creative and have
some outlets uh while we're all
you know hunkered down like i said so
yeah tell us about your solo album what
inspired it and is it
is this something that's going to be
coming out in the next few months when
can we expect it
yeah so i um i felt inspired to do
another record um mainly because
you know like i said all all the guys
were were kind of in different places
right now and we can't really travel and
be with each other and do things so
like aj is doing his podcast he was just
on dance with the stars
yeah um and so i said well you maybe
this will be a cool way to
to kind of give something to the fans
you know in the meantime you know record
some music
put some stuff out i mean we can even
though we got to be back home and we can
only
listen to music and watch movies right
now you know
maybe that's a way that we could still
stay connected and and so yeah i just
felt inspired to get
into the studio and start writing music
and um
and recording some uh some music and so
to answer the question
uh i'd like to have something at least
maybe like a single or something out
maybe even this christmas uh i think
this one before um
in the meantime i love that and talking
about aj dancing with the stars i mean
he came in seventh place you came in
second place right in season 21 so you
did a little bit better than him
have you been watching him have you been
giving him tips on how to
how to dance yeah so i was
i i okay all i'm gonna say is aj
i look up to aj aj is an incredible
dancer like he
is i think he's much better of a dancer
than i am
um but maybe that's just me being you
know
i wanted him to go all the way i wanted
him to beat me i really did
and still i still think that he got cut
a little bit too early
um but you know uh he was proud i talked
to him after
he was he was he was actually he said he
was a little relieved that it was over
because it is a lot of work you know
yeah
it's it can be um uh you know
hard at times you know because it's
strenuous on your body he's like my
knees are hurting oh my god i'm like
so on one end he wanted to go all the
way but on another
kind of happiest little that he's done
but i was i was really proud of him
for how what he did and how far he
actually went
do you watch a show called masked singer
yeah i've watched it
yeah have you seen the crocodile yeah
i've seen uh
people have been saying some things but
[Laughter]
you're just watching it you're just and
honestly like i'm just i'm
i haven't had a chance to really watch
much other than
okay youtube videos and yeah people
think you're the crocodile i don't know
i mean
who knows
you